[Music]
next is david from new york we got two
new york calls here david welcome to the
show
all right check check can y'all hear me
yeah we can hear you david how can we
help you're the last call on friday
oh that's beautiful that's beautiful
life is good um so i hope y'all are
doing well i just had a very um
well to me is an interesting question
y'all probably get this all the time but
me and my lady was sitting down last
night
my beautiful wife
and i'm very grateful because
we are 99.9 percent
aligned nice
on the entire budget amazing okay what's
the 0.1 percent
her position is as follows okay well
um
i feel
that there should be a line item in the
budget
for personal expenditures because if i
want to go get my nails done i should be
able to do that and i said baby listen
my position is as follows there's going
to be a time
when you can get your nails done every
other day you can get your hair done
every week
for now
we got to eliminate the personal
expenditures entirely stick to the plan
and aggressively build up
this emergency fund
so my question is whoa she being a
princess
am i being too rigid am i being too
rigid or is there some kind of
compromise right question
okay well i need to know first david are
you guys when you say you're working for
your emergency fund so are you out of
debt and you're working for your fully
funded emergency fund
that's correct okay awesome well
congratulations
um
i'm i'm gonna go i
i'm i'm going to be in the middle here
i'm going to be in the middle in a lot
of money either okay so david i'm i'm
i'm going to be a little bit on her side
because here's what we have found even
if it's like even if it's not a lot of
money just something small something
small because it's realistic and that's
what the budget is supposed to reflect
yes it's supposed to reflect sacrifice
to get
that emergency fund funded as quickly as
possible so i'm with you on that like i
hear that intensity and it's like yes um
but you also want to be realistic so
does she need to go and get her nails
done
every week no she doesn't so but can she
treat herself to something small
um once a month that has a little bit of
money in there and again it may not be
what she wants because you guys are kind
of you are still in that season of
sacrifice but it at least gives a a
little bit of that of that breathing
room and motivation to be like okay i
kind of get my you know that scratch
itched somewhere uh else other than
feeling like i'm going 300
into like the beauty section of life of
hair and nails and stuff until that
emergency fund is funded that's it but
it's a great question dave but it's one
a lot of people have